good evening and welcome to fox news
prime time
i'm trey gowdy thank you again for
joining us tonight
well that didn't last long
joe biden kamala harris and the
mainstream media love to talk about
unity
these are the words of president bible
just moments after he took the oath of
office
my whole soul was in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause
last night and early this morning the
united states senate split
50 50 on a number of amendments
democrats are using a process called
reconciliation
which is a really weird word to use when
there's no reconciliation at all
but they're using that price process to
bypass the republicans
that's not unity that's raw power
yesterday president biden criticized
former secretary of state mike pompeo
over foreign policy is back diplomacy
is back at the center of our foreign
policy
we must restore the health and morale of
our foreign policy institutions
that's not unity kamala harris thinks
telling west virginia coal miners to
start clearing land mines is unifying
probably probably because she will not
be the one clearing those land mines
she even went to west virginia to put
pressure on a democrat to get in line
that's not unifying either that's just
raw politics
listen to what democrat senator joe
manchin said in response
i couldn't believe it no one called me
we're going to try to find a bipartisan
pathway for it i think we need to
but we need to work together that's not
a way of working together
and of course next week house and senate
democrats are going to try to remove
someone from office
who isn't even in office and then bar
him from
ever holding office again they have no
chance of a conviction
they have no chance of barring donald
trump from future office
they cannot get a conviction but they
will march
forward anyway not because they think
they can win in court
but because they think it will help them
win elections
that doesn't sound very unifying unity
is defined as a state of
oneness a state of being joined as a
whole
the senate is 50 50 the house is almost
equally divided that doesn't sound like
oneness to me
so if it's unity we're looking for it's
not going to come from a speech and it's
not going to come from government and
it's not going to come from politics
it's going to have to come from us and
it will be a process
sometimes a lengthy process but like all
journeys
you're not going to get there unless you
start walking
the super bowl is sunday i probably
won't watch because dallas isn't playing
i'll probably go in the other room and
watch hallmark movies with my wife
actually that sounds awful so i probably
will watch the game after all
there are rules in football there are
rules in golf we have rules in every
every facet of life some are written
most are not
but we know them and we follow them in
politics
they're just no rules the objective is
simply to win
the end justifies the means and power
is the currency of politics i mean if
you're serious about unity
stop looking for the 50 50 issues and
focus on those things for which there is
consensus
we want this virus defeated we want jobs
we want
economic opportunity we want our
children to be educated we want to be
safe americans would rather see a sermon
than hear a sermon so why don't we start
there
practice what you preach now that
would really be unifying
here to respond former white house press
secretary and
fox news contributor the great ari
fleischer ari how are you
gerry great to see you
what do you make of this unity
juxtaposed with 50 50 votes in the
senate and using the reconciliation
process to jam
something down people's throats well
first of all you're lying about i've
never heard that saying before about
americans rather see a sermon than hear
a sermon that's a beautiful thing to say
that that is you just captured so much
in that one sentence
but in terms of what we're seeing in
washington and with joe biden
the centrist the one who wants to be a
unifier his whole soul is in it
what i've come to the conclusion is half
his soul is in it
the other half of his soul is not in it
and kamala harris is going to cast the
tie-breaking vote for his soul
joe biden wants to be the unifier but he
certainly isn't governing
like the unifier if he wanted to unify
there is no question we'd be on a
bipartisan path right now
and there's nothing wrong with if you've
got the votes shove it through
but that's how lbj linda baines johnson
would govern and he made no bones about
it
he didn't say he was a unifier joe biden
said he's a unifier
he's not a unifier well let's give
let's just give joe biden the benefit of
half the doubt all right the half of him
that wants to be the unifier
i don't think any part of his base is
going to let that half live very long i
mean i i just i don't think they're
going to allow it
am i wrong no that's exactly
the problem that if he thinks he wants
to be a unifier he gets buffeted by the
forces of progressive progress
progressivism and he can't stand up to
them because
he's just too weak and you saw in his
presidential run
when he ran for president he abandoned
many of the centrist positions he used
to take as a senator
he used to be against taxpayer-funded
abortions he came out against it when he
ran for president
he was a tough on crime senator then he
came out and did 180
on that he kept backing off joe biden's
old positions to increasingly become the
voice and the spokesman for the
progressive left
to the point where bernie sanders said
he'll be the most progressive president
we've ever had
so biden is proving bernie right and
that's a real problem for america
ari one of the reasons i love to talk to
you is because i think you make an
effort to be fair and you kind of call
it like you see it
you had one of the toughest jobs in all
of washington
sitting white house dealing with the
dealing with the press corps
has the media changed since you were in
the bush administration and how do we
get that societal referee back
trey it's night and day it is 100
different back then and that was just
what almost 20 years ago the press was
liberal
they'd been liberal for decades but they
acted and tried to be
down the middle they did think it was
part of their job to report the news
fully fairly and accurately
and poll after poll the gallup poll the
pew poll
shows that the majority of the american
people do not think the press tells the
news fully fairly and accurately
they're too biased from the start
they're too liberal when they come into
journalism school they're made even more
liberal
in the course of their political careers
especially for younger journalists now
who are lighting newsrooms on fire with
rebellions against fairness
against neutrality journalism is broken
trey
and the only thing that'll make it come
back is that when they talk about
diversity
they actually practice ideological
diversity
it would strengthen them it would let
them see half the country that they
really don't do a good job seeing and it
would stop them from making a lot of
mistakes
because they wouldn't have ideological
blinders on where the only people they
bounce things off of
are similar minded people that's the
only thing i think that'll save
journalism
all right we've got about a minute but
you talked about newsroom should be
split
speaking of split we're going to have a
jury trial of sorts next week with a
split jury
i don't think a single one of them has
not already made up their minds what's
the smart way for republicans
to handle next week get it over as
quickly as possible or
what what would you suggest well the
democratic strategy is consistent with
everything they did after joe biden
became the nominee
continue to shine a light on donald
trump and keep all the lights off of joe
biden
this is their strategy they don't want
the focus to be on joe biden so the
republicans this is a waste of time as
you point out
donald trump will not be convicted
donald trump will not be removed from
office he already is
he won't be barred from running again
that's a decision the american people
should make
the democrats have an interest in
stretching this out republicans should
keep it short it's a waste of time get
it over with
great advice i hope they're listening
ari thank you hope you have a great
weekend thanks for joining us tonight
thank you trey